gonna do sexual favors y'all call yeah
Michael all right
give this gentleman here Holocaust
Survivor hey God you must eat his
[__] my sentence you to fellatio
[Music]
uh we got another classic classic
catfish tail here my favorite love them
um we'll show you I'll show you the
catfish first just because uh why not
she's a honey dude I don't know I don't
want to say anything mean it's the one
she used or is this the ones that she is
she is that's who she is oh I was like
damn dude if that's the catfish what's
behind the other door say something nice
everyone say one nice thing about her
she's not ugly honestly
that's the nicest thing you can think of
I agree with Nick I don't agree with
Nick yeah she she looks funny
she has nice eyes yeah she has nice eyes
she does good makeup she does have nice
eyes genuinely nice well I know for me
though like okay you don't need to
catfish yeah I don't think maybe you
need a catfish if you want a guy that's
way [__] out of your league but then
like she there's she doesn't look like a
girl that's like like can't get a
boyfriend yeah that's that's what I mean
yeah like maybe she can't get Tom Hardy
but like yeah you want to deal with all
that yeah yeah he's only a Blue Bell
I mean this guy like that but uh the
thing that makes this a little bit more
of a news if you will is the person that
she catfished or is this elderly
Holocaust Survivor oh no what does she
know
she probably didn't know she probably
knew dude
what kind of conversations would she
have like I'm sure he would only talk
and how horny is this [__] he's
got to be 90 and he's getting his horns
on for this he's got to be pretty old
he's 87 years old I bet he talks about
the hall cost a lot so survival swindled
out of his life savings
Fish Man by a woman he met on a dating
website uh prosecutors allege in this uh
romance scam her name is Peaches by the
way okay peaches Sturgill a 36 year old
Florida woman her actual name speeches
apparently wow uh also known as Alice
though was arrested Wednesday on one
count of wire fraud for allegedly duping
an 87 year old man out of over 2.8
million dollars what a [__] dude what I
got that kind of money it's a lot of
nasty gold are there any reparations for
Holocaust Survivors monetarily from
anybody I doubt it he followed our tax
dollars he's good at saving money
because he's Jewish baby wow how dare
you compliment dollars that's a
compliment dude hey take it easy maybe
he has a really good one but you got to
be like that's a Next Level heartless
but he's also 87 years old that's a long
time to save that money you know Joe
maybe some Jews are bad with money dude
you ever thought about that yeah that's
[__] up I never seen it
all the guys that I know that are Jewish
they're really good and and Jewish
people are have the best confidence as
teenagers they're so funny
you want mitzvah
and kids on the planet no why no they're
just they're just the level of
confidence yeah the joke as soon as it's
like it's just out they don't stop
anything is this funny they just kill it
no non-stop yeah they just know they're
the best so uh yeah 2.8 million dollars
that she used apparently to buy Rolex
watches a boat and other luxury items
all depreciating assets by the way not
smart bad move out there don't some of
the Rolexes could be good yeah oh yeah
the Rollies are pretty good yeah but
which ones a day-date boat's the worst
thing
uh quote the defendant callously prayed
on a senior citizen simply seeking
companionship defrauding him of his life
savings is it though he got didn't he
get his companionship back though he
probably [__] on a couple of
handkerchiefs
I'm scared of anybody with that
capability to Omit guilt to that level
Sturgill according to the indictment met
the unidentified victim a then Manhattan
resident on a dating website six or
seven years ago by 2017 she asked him
for money to pay her attorney so she
could receive settlement funds she
claimed were owed to her according to
the prosecutors the settlement that's a
good story that's a really good story
really good over the next five years
prosecutors alleged Sturgill fed the
victim continuous lies to receive almost
monthly checks often in increments of
fifty thousand
monthly checks the impersonated a bank
employee sent fake invoices and created
a phony email account to reassure the
victim that he would be repaid if he
continued to deposit money into the
account accordingly I want to see what
kind of picture she used it said that
she's kind of resourceful like she could
have really done some cool [__] low-key
this sounds [__] up but like some of
the catfishes like they like
they should get more money dude
because because they should get more
props like the tinders like like hey man
have you seen that have you seen the
Monty Taylor yeah that [__] didn't get
[__] but like she didn't get [__] but
she was like as far as like the best
catfishers of all time she's in the Hall
of Fame FBI couldn't tell that's what
I'm saying like like if you're that good
at catfishing she's good but but she
doesn't have like a [__] Rolex Hulk
yeah she was doing it for the love you
know what I'm saying she got a
Submariner she doesn't have a Pepsi I'll
tell you that this chick is on another
level 50 Grand a month is a lot I mean
dude that's a that's a whole ass
business you use the money to buy a home
in a gated community a condominium a
boat and numerous cars how did she file
her taxes like what is her taxes the
personator tax guy prosecutors alleged
also used his his money to travel buy
gold and silver bars jewelry and
designer clothing okay the golden suit
okay that's good that's smart by 2021
the alleged victim confided in his son
that he had given Sturgill his life
savings based on her promises that he
would be paid back according to court
documents it was the son like that was
my inheritance after yeah after his son
told him that he had been scammed the
victim stopped writing checks he lost
his apartment according to the
indictment oh no one more photo of her
face with the caption Holocaust
Survivors hate her for this one simple
trick she had more than one simple trick
though dude she had a couple bro she was
doing an active do that to someone like
that yeah the sun's a hater huh yeah the
ruin his dad's such a [__] block yeah
wait does that mean he was a child in
the in the during the Holocaust
Holocaust Survivor does that mean you
were in a camp or does that mean like
you just survived the era
I think I shouldn't answer that question
I like that Joe's the Holocaust referee
Wait a Minute
review the plane yeah
and starve yeah yeah when I hear of um
Holocaust Survivor I I Hear What I Hear
is Schindler's List people are like in
the camp but there might be some fakers
and they got rescued yeah so I was like
oh because then like when you when you
watch these like Holocaust Survivor
whatever they have like tattoos not all
of them go to Camp right imagine like
the moment where it's like you're just
running away from being caught yeah we
don't question enough yeah
I just want to know what that means
leave it to Anthony man to jump in with
Joe
Camp right some people didn't go leave
it to Steve the one the one German guy
here that's what I'm saying I stayed
away I'm not touching hot German we're
not Axis Powers okay we were we were
born on this side especially now that
Joe added my ethnicity I was trying to
keep it all secret but some people will
smuggle out of the country that was him
like had different methods of getting
out of the country to avoid persecution
yeah they all count as survivors oh okay
okay thank you Ryan so it's like saying
like Syrian refugee or whatever or it's
like saying Holocaust Survivor
you survived the Holocaust okay fine
Hannah says I'm a pure blood German by
the way so yeah clean up your except
you're the one who said Aryan earlier
I did I did say purebred areas
uh so it says here um uh feudal Japanese
people also can't talk about Holocaust
feel Japanese
oh [__]
oh if convicted struggle could face as
many as 20 years in prison although Nick
believes she should get paid more
give her a little bit a little bit of
shine
with such a good operation I think it
was when the sun was like or the dad was
like I'm out of money the son was like
hey you're getting scared and the dad's
like I gotta stop writing checks
and then call the cops but like Nick
saying like they should they should put
her to work finding other catfishes like
this [__] is good at what she does oh
like to catch me if you can type things
exactly like Frank Williams make her a
Dexter yeah you hire the hacker because
think about all the old people that are
just getting scammed out there like that
[__] is really happening I feel like
they want it they want the scam to be
real that's why they keep doing it it
says that the Federal Trade Commission
said losses from romance scams hit a
record 547 million dollars in 2021 it's
a movie more than six times the 87
million dollars lost in 2017. it's a
it's a big boom man you know what I
think should happen to make it equal
where they don't have to pay back all
the sexual favors you said you were
gonna perform just execute it because
they already paid for it that's true you
should have to do it yeah
there should be a court order for it
gonna do sexual favors yo I'll call yeah
Michael all right
I'm in here Holocaust Survivor a [__]
you must eat his [__] my sentence you
to fellatio
for 20 years
50 years of oral sex I would uh I I kind
of like Joe Malia more and more as it
gets rolled out yeah it's very fair
that's what I want to do I never thought
I would ever hear someone go but what it
really does make a holocaust Survivor
hold on yeah he's like everyone's like
come on come on okay okay wait a minute
did you uh go to Camp did you go to camp
Hey if you grew up in London are you a
holocaust Survivor no right that's what
I'm saying I don't know if you were a
little boy in Argentina and you were a
little bit hungry does that make you a
refugee
not really not not to me you can't keep
up with these rules
it was it's been real man it's been real
JK it's been [__] real
[Music]
are you there
[Applause]
oh wow oh wow
hey hey
[Applause]
it's been fun yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]